hello and welcome to presentation about
dopaminergic neurons and some of the
work that we've been doing in our
laboratory concerning the physiology of
these neurons especially as they relate
to disease things what I'll be talking
about a different animal models of
disease and specifically schizophrenia
and depression and try to give you an
understanding of how we think these
systems are involved now certainly we
can't actually have a model of the human
disease schizophrenia since this is a
unique human disorder but what I hope to
show you is by modeling the different
systems that clinical science has shown
us are involved in schizophrenia and
depression we can grant a gain a greater
understanding of the systems that are
involved in this disorder now I'll be
talking about the dopaminergic system
the dopaminergic system is located in
the midbrain of a rat and the midbrain
of a human in this case what we have
retire seeing hydroxylase labeled
neurons in the bright yellow colors that
show you the ventral tegmental area in
the substantia [ __ ] now in order to try
to understand the physiology of these
neurons what we want to do is to record
from identified dopaminergic neurons
now dopaminergic neurons are intermixed
with other types of neurons and in order
to identify them we may take advantage
of their unique neuro chemical
properties in the slide that you're
seeing what we have is a technique
called black silly casting fluorescence
what this is is it labels the dopamine
in the dopaminergic neurons with an
intensely fluorescent product in this
case one of the neurons the very bright
one was injected with l-dopa
the l-dopa was then converted into
dopamine and caused a much greater level
of fluorescence which enabled us to
identify these neurons and to associate
an electrophysiological signature with
the neurochemical identity of these
neurons this was also done using
immunohistochemistry in this case a
neuron was injected with the dye Lucifer
yellow which then was counterstain
tyrosine hydroxylase to identify the
neuron now the dopaminergic neurons have
unusual morphological features they have
dendrites that extend far from the soma
they have an initial segment where the
gives rise to the axon so the axon
actually comes up in the dendrite rather
than soma and this contributes to their
unique electro physiological properties
as you see in this case the dopaminergic
neurons have this slow - polarization
that leads it up to a very depolarize
spike threshold and this slowed the
polarization and high spike threshold
contribute to the unique features the
dopaminergic neurons have this slurred
of polarization of the soma that have to
deplore eyes despite generating
mechanism on the dendrite so even though
the spike generation in the dendrite is
going to be the constant level how its
measured in the soma is going to bury
quite a bit and this is going to give
the the action potential a rather unique
type waveform that actually buries
action potential - action potential now
dopaminergic neurons as you can see in
this case where we have a intracellular
recording an extracellular recording and
a differentiation differentiation of the
intracellular recording the neurons do
not have a triphasic action potential
anytime you see a triphasic action
potential it's due to villain filtering
which often leads problems with
identification now once we identified
the neuron we want to get an idea of
what the activity of the neuron looks
like in order to do this we need to look
across the population dopaminergic
neurons rather than just looking at a
single a single neuron we know that
about half the neurons in a normal
animal of firing spontaneously about
half of them are non firing in order to
find out just what proportion you're
firing what we do is passing electron
through the ventral tegmental area and
count the number of neurons that we see
firing this gives us an idea of the
population activity
about how many neurons are firing for
every neuron firing we see what it's
firing rate is how fast it's firing and
also it's firing pattern because the
firing pattern itself has a rather
unique property so in normal animals at
a baseline state dopaminergic neurons
fire and rather slow irregular papapapa
type of firing rate and as you see
there's quite a bit of differentiation
from action potential to action
potential as far as amplitude but when
an animal experience a behaviorally
salient stimulus as shown by Wolfram
Schultz and others what we get are
bursts and action potentials so these
bursts of action potentials are actually
the behaviorally salient output of the
dopamine system burst firing is actually
driven by glutamatergic inputs coming
primarily from the pedunculopontine
tegmentum if we activate this area by
blocking glutamate and GABA what we get
is an activation of the excitatory drive
this leads to a selective increase just
in bursts firing without really
affecting the other proper properties of
the of the fire of the neuron as far as
the number of neurons firing or firing
rate and this has to do with the
properties of the neuron itself what we
know is that this pedunculopontine
tegmentum comes in and provides a
glutamatergic input onto NMDA receptors
on the dopaminergic neurons however for
an NMDA receptor to be activated and
cause burst firing what we have the
neuron has to be depolarized if it's
hyperpolarized there's a magnesium block
of the NMDA channel and you don't get an
effect so basically you only get NMDA
driving and burst firing and neurons
that are already firing spontaneously
now what regulates the number of neurons
firing spontaneously this seems to be
driven by the ventral pallidum
studies done by Leslie beer and Gordon
Mogensen have shown that the bench
is an intensely GABAergic area the tires
in very high frequencies this high
frequencies holds the non firing neurons
in a hyperpolarized non firing state
however if the ventral pallidum
influence is removed this GABAergic
inhibition is removed and the neurons
now all start to fire in a spontaneously
firing pattern now what's the relevance
of this tonic neuron firing the number
of neurons firing basically it provides
the level of amplification of the system
so for example the ventral pallidum is
controlling a number of neurons firing
but the pedunculopontine causes burst
firing but only in the number of
building the firing neurons so the
ventral the pedunculopontine provides
the signal for the increase in burst
firing but the ventral pallidum provides
the gain or the level of amplification B
signal so the more derives the ventral
pallidum causes to fire the more neurons
the particular pontine can cause the
burst fire now the pallidum itself is
made regulated by multiple converging
systems one potent regulator in the bed
repellent is a pathway that involves the
ventral hippocampus and nucleus
accumbens in fact if we activate the
ventral hippocampus by injecting NMDA
what we find is we get a selective
increase in the number of neurons firing
by more than two and a half times
without changing the firing pattern or
the firing rate now the ventral
hippocampus doesn't project directly to
the dopaminergic neurons but thus so
through a circuitous route involving the
accumbens and ventral pallidum and in
fact if we block this glutamatergic
hippocampus to accumbens pathway by
infusing the glutamate blocker tiny
erratic acid and adventure with the
campus we prevent all of the effects of
ventral hippocampus activation now this
event is consistent with what we know
about the system the hippocampus
provides an excitatory Drive
the accumbens the accumbens then
inhibits the ventral pallidum
soin hippocampus is activated it removes
metropolitan ambition and activates the
neuronal firing now this system appears
to play a major role in the psychotic
symptoms of schizophrenia we have used
an animal model of schizophrenia based
on a developmental disruption using a
compound methylated oxy methanol acetate
or ma'am and this has provided us with
unique insights into the dopaminergic
system and the circuitry that controls
it in a way that's actually quite
consistent with clinical studies that
have been done now the mem developmental
model of schizophrenia has been found to
have the number of characteristics that
are consistent with what we would expect
for an animal model in schizophrenia we
see changes in the anatomy of the adult
animal after the mam was given to the
pregnant female during gestation of day
17 specifically a thinning of limbic
cortical structures in fact the same
cortical structures that are thin in the
human schizophrenia brain postmortem
instead of a loss of neurons there's an
increased self packing density this is
also consistent with what's been
reported in human schizophrenia patients
we see behavioral evidence in terms of
deficits and in sensory gating such as
pre pulse in addition of startle
impairments and executive functions such
as reversal learning and extra
dimensional shift impairments in
negative symptoms such as latent
inhibition and social interaction we
also see pharmacological evidence
consistent with schizophrenia such as an
increased behavioral response to PCP
something that's been seen in
schizophrenia patients and also an
increased locomotor response to
amphetamine just as schizophrenia
patients showed increased response to
amphetamine that's no different that is
emerges in the adult animal but not when
the animals in the pre-pubertal stage
the time when we don't believe that
there's a change in the dopaminergic
system now the increased fme response is
consistent with the amphetamine induced
openly released observant schizophrenia
patients in fact there's a bit of
evidence to show that the dopaminergic
system is involved in schizophrenia for
example all antipsychotic drugs that are
in use today are primarily dopaminergic
antagonists second drugs an increase on
ketamine dopamine release such as FN
amine or l-dopa will exacerbate
psychosis in schizophrenia patients as
well as induces psychotic State and
controls that have high doses of these
compounds furthermore imaging studies
done by Abby garnered mark Laurel and
others have shown that there's an
increased FME induced dopamine release
measured by rockler prior displacement
and human schizophrenia patients we
furthermore the amplitude of the
increased dopamine release correlates
with the ability to amphetamine to
worsen the psychosis
so what we have is an identity between
increased dopamine release and the
psychotic features of schizophrenia
however despite years of research
there's little evidence for a primary
deficit from the dopamine system itself
instead we now believe the dopamine
system itself is probably normal
but it's dysregulated by other
structures and one key structured seems
to be the campus so in the man mom with
schizophrenia there's a hyper
responsibility the dopamine system
that's functionally analogous to what's
seen in schizophrenia patients in
current clinical data shows that
hyperactivity in the hippocampus using
functional MRI correlates with the
psychotic state of schizophrenia now is
the hippocampus hyperactive in the mam
animal as it is in studies in humans
schizophrenia patients well if we just
look at hippocampal neuron firing rate
in the ventral hippocampus we find that
the neurons are on average firing
significantly faster but of course the
hippocampus is a complex structure whose
activity depends more than just on the
firing rate of the neurons but also on
rhythmic activity
when we look at rhythmic activity we
find something interesting we find that
there's a decrease in the low-frequency
rhythms the rhythms that we think are
responsible for functional gating and
instead an increase in the higher
frequency rhythms which means that when
removing what would be a gated output
and replacing it with the high frequency
noise if he will coming out of the
hippocampus now how does this affect
dopaminergic neuron activity well before
when we directly activated the potential
hippocampus
we got an increase in dopamine
population activity in this case
whenever we look at the NAMM animal we
see the same thing an increase by more
than two fold in the number of neurons
firing without a change in average
firing rate or average firing pattern so
the increase in the number of
dopaminergic neurons firing is a likely
correlate of what we see in human
studies in human studies by house and
Maguire what they find is there's an
increase fluorodopa uptake in ultra-high
risk in schizophrenia patients in
Australia fluorodopa would be taken up
in dopaminergic terminals that are
active so the more terminals that are
active the higher the fluorodopa uptake
and similarly the more neurons we see
firing the more terminals should be
active so there's a pretty strong
correlate between what's seen in the
animal model in what's seen in given
schizophrenia patients now we believe
that this is occurring through the
hippocampus because if we inactivate the
hippocampus we can reverse this
so injecting TTX in the hippocampus
doesn't really affect the baseline
firing in the normal animal but then the
man treated animal brings the number of
neurons firing right back to control
levels without affecting the other
parameters of dopaminergic neuron
activity now what I've been talking
about is electrophysiological properties
but is this something that can actually
translate into
but what we had recorded is whatever you
give a shot at amphetamine to admit to a
control animal you get an increase in
locomotor response - including but in
the man animal what we see is a much
greater increase to amphetamine compared
to the control however if we inactivate
the hippocampus something that restores
dopaminergic neuron firing the baseline
we also bring the behavioral response to
amphetamine back to the control baseline
we don't block it
we just restore it to baseline levels so
in dopaminergic neuron activity is
restored the activity response to
amphetamine is also restored
therefore the hippocampal overdrive
needed to increase dopamine neuron
population activity appears to be the
basis for this type of responsibility at
the dopamine system that seems to
encourage schizophrenia now how does the
increase in dopamine population activity
affect the response of the dopamine
system to behaviorally say any stimulant
in other words how does this translate
to pathology
well the hippocampus especially the
ventral to the campus is believed to be
involved in what's called
context-dependent processing or the
ability to interpret stimuli based on
their context hippocampus does this in a
dopamine system by controlling the
number of dopaminergic neurons active so
if you're in a benign or a safe context
the ventral hippocampus doesn't have a
lot of dopaminergic neurons active the
proportion of neurons firing is small so
if you end up having a behaviorally
salient stimulus that occurs like
hearing a noise in the background
although it will activate the
pedunculopontine
tegmentum the dopamine release is going
to be rather small because of the small
number of neurons fire so for example if
you're sitting in a safe environment and
a house behind locked doors and you hear
a noise you're going to react to that
noise by looking around and seeing what
happened but you're not going to have
too strong of a reaction because you
don't expect any
dangerous to be tapping on the other
hand if you're in an activating context
let's say you're an animal out hunting
where every noise could potentially be
something that you can eat and be
rewarding or something that can eat you
and be a negative stimulus in this case
the ventral hippocampus amygdala has the
dopamine system turned up very odd there
are a lot of neurons firing now the same
noise that didn't cause much of an
activation before is going to cause a
much greater increase in dopamine
release and you're going to activate an
orient and prepare to react to whatever
stimulus is happening at the time what
about the case of schizophrenia in this
case the ventral Civic ulam in
hippocampus is over driven the dopamine
system itself is over driven basically
all the neurons are firing spontaneously
now whenever is say a stimulus comes in
and it could be a salient or a non
salient stimulus you're going to get a
massive activation of the dopamine
system and this is consistent with what
we think is happening in schizophrenia
so in the case of schizophrenia a
stimulus is going to come in and cause a
massive dopamine release independent of
its importance which means the
schizophrenia patient is going to be
constantly bombarded with stimuli
without really the ability to decide
which stimuli are important and should
be paid attention to and which ones can
be safely ignored because they're all
going to be bombarding the sensorium
competing for attention something in
schizophrenia patients complaining about
it's also going to interfere with
interpretation stimuli because what we
have is that the schizophrenia patient
right let's say a normal person if they
see two complete strangers talking to
each other across the street this is
something most of us can safely ignore
because this wouldn't be a threatening
stimulus but when a schizophrenic sees
this they're going to get a massive
activation of the dopamine system which
means now the dopamine system is going
to be screaming at the brain this is
something essential
our survival what is it about this
that's so dangerous which means they're
going to start to confabulate or make up
ideas about why this is such a dangerous
event the ideas such as these are aliens
planning to abduct them that this is the
CIA spying on them or these magical
types of thoughts something that you
teach the poor is referred to as
aberrant salience or the improper
attribution of importance to what should
be a benign stimulus so in the
hippocampus is hyperactive the dopamine
system is hyper responses to stimuli and
results in over interpretation of events
now how can we fix the dopamine system
instead siffredi well currently
schizophrenia is treated by blocking
excess dopamine receptor stimulation
using antagonists and dopamine
antagonists antipsychotic drugs however
even what we now understand about the
pathophysiology of schizophrenia in the
dopamine system this is not likely to be
the most effective strategy so what we
believe is that at least with respect to
psychosis the deficit lies in the
hippocampus in the GABAergic inhibition
of hippocampal neurons but we currently
treat schizophrenia by blocking dopamine
at the dopamine receptor in other words
we block it one two three four five
synapses downstream from where we think
the actual problem is so it's not a
surprise that the drugs that are used
the treat schizophrenia may not be the
most effective and of course these drugs
weren't really developed the treat
schizophrenia it was founded it be
effective in schizophrenia
serendipitously in fact a number of
years before dopamine was actually
discovered to be a transmitter in the
brain and well before these drugs were
found to act by blocking dopamine
receptors the better approach would be
to treat at the site of pathology so in
order to do this what we would like to
do is to fix what's wrong
in other words we want to be able to
replace the parvalbumin GABAergic
interneurons the things that seem to be
lost in schizophrenia in schizophrenia
both the man-animals and the
schizophrenia patient there is a loss of
these Pardo diamond GABAergic inter
neurons that supply gaba inhibition to
the Campbell neurons what we would like
to do is to fix the system now it's
probably broken because of the parvo
vehement interneuron loss parvalbumin
inter neurons are actually driven by
glutamate working on NMDA receptors
which is probably where PCP acts to
mimic schizophrenia and to exacerbate
this instinctive for any patients now to
fix this we could potentially together
but gaba or 132 synapses in the brain so
this isn't something that we can do
selectively on the other hand the
GABAergic synapses in the hippocampus
have a unique composition in that they
have a GABA a alpha 5 subunit now the
GABA a receptor is to participate
dimeric structure composed of alpha beta
and gamma means the alpha subunit where
benzodiazepines bonding so normal
benzodiazepines will bind to the alpha 1
alpha 2 subunits the potentiate GABA but
in the hippocampus we have a unique
concentration of gaba-a receptors with
the alpha subunit what we did is to
obtain the selective GABA a alpha 5
benzodiazepine from Jim Cooke and
Madison Wisconsin that should
selectively potentially Gavin at the
candles what we find is that this is
what this drug does if we look at this
drug and look at a effect of a
excitatory synapse stimulating the
internal cortex and recording the
hippocampus low doses of this drug
potent in block this effect by
potentiating Gabon hippocampus but if we
look at a different brain region
for example the fill a mechanic
glutamate response in the cingulate
cortex even ten times the dose of this
drug has no effect so it does seem to be
selected for inhibiting pip example
activity what about with respect to the
man model where we see an increase in
the number of neurons firing well if we
give this drug it doesn't really do much
to control animals but in the mam
animals what it does is bring dopamine
neuron firing right back down to control
levels we also see the same thing with
respect to behavior this drug has very
variable effects an amphetamine induced
behavioral response and Saleen animals
but in the man treated animals the
amphetamine hyper Rick had the
responsibility is restored right back
down to baseline so just like in the
case of the dopaminergic neuron firing
when dopamine neuron fire Muser stored
the baseline the behavior response is
also restored to baseline so in
schizophrenia and the mam model its
interneuron dysfunction may be a primary
driving symptomatology if we can restore
inter neuron function we could have an
effective therapeutic strategy to treat
schizophrenia and potentially other
disorders that involve these types of
inter neuron dysfunctions however
treating schizophrenia once it's emerged
can be problematic we know from clinical
studies that the longer a person has
untreated schizophrenia the worse the
prognosis a better approach would be as
if we could treat schizophrenia
premorbid to prevent the emergence of
schizophrenia in the transition to
psychosis now how can we do this well we
know that stress is something that plays
a major role in schizophrenia and other
disorders stressful stimuli and
schizophrenia patients are known to
exacerbate the positive symptoms this
disorder we know that stress can play a
role in the etiology of schizophrenia in
fact II John Stone found that if she
looked at a number of children that were
at genetic risk for schizophrenia in the
juvenile state before they showed any
symptoms
and looked at their characteristic one
thing she found are the children that
were hyper responsive distress tended to
be the ones that converted schizophrenia
now stress itself is known to induce
through the corticoid release and also
need to be careful damage and in fact
Francine Bennie's showed that activating
stress circuits for example by
activating the amygdala can drive
hippocampal activity and also lead to
par dopamine neuron loss so in normal
individuals we think that the effects of
stress can be mitigated by areas like
the prefrontal cortex
however these schizophrenia patient
there's evidence that the prefrontal
cortex may actually show some initial
deficits if that's the case the
prefrontal cortex may not be able to
mitigate these effects so in the normal
individual stress activates the
dopaminergic input to the frontal cortex
which activates frontal cortical neuron
firing and feeds back and give its
distress response however if there's a
damage the prefrontal cortex double
energic input or dopaminergic regulation
in the prefrontal cortex we're going to
get this regulated dopaminergic systems
which are going to contribute distress
will get less prefrontal down regulation
of the amygdala which itself is going to
contribute to stress this will also
activate the dhanraj allergic system in
the locus coeruleus which will further
exacerbate stress together leading to
hippocampal overdrive and hippocampal
damage in this reentrant loop where the
damage needs the more stress which leads
to more damage now are the mem treated
rats more sensitive the stressors as is
proposed to the current schizophrenia
but when we look at the man treated rats
we find that they do indeed react more
strongly to stress for example if we do
a mild foot shock something that will
cause activation of vocalization
normally the mam treated animals will
get a much greater localization which
means that
negative effects of the foot shock are
amplified in the man treated animal
furthermore the animals themselves are
also more anxious if we look at the
elevated plus maze what we find is where
normal animals will explore open
enclosed arms the man treated animals
tend to hide into closed arms which is
consistent with increased levels of
anxiety furthermore if we look at the
HPA axis we also see a disruption for
example if we look at critic Castro
which is the rat equivalent of the human
cortisol where we find is if we give a
mild fruit Chuck we get a huge
activation of cortisol in the normal
animal but a blunted response in the
manual but if we repeat it for ten days
although the normal animal shows
tremendous accommodation the man animal
doesn't share a change now this is
significant because cortisol release is
necessary in order to mount a
homeostatic response if there's no
cortisol blunted cortisol activation
you're not going to be able to mount a
partly homeostatic response so mam rats
also show this abnormal homeostatic
response to stress if stress plays a
role in the developmental etiology of
schizophrenia this would suggest in
early intervention in susceptible
individuals they help to prevent the
transition psychosis and we tested it in
the man models by administering the
anti-anxiety agent I as Pam paired k-mer
so what we did is to treat animals with
either pregnant downs with either mam or
saline then for a 10-day period around
puberty we gave the animals diazepam
cookies or same and then looked at the
animals as adults after a substantial
withdrawal of the diazepam and what we
found is that although it didn't have an
effect in the Saline animals and the mam
animals it restored dopaminergic neuron
firing or prevented the activation of
dopaminergic neuron firing and prevented
the exacerbated behavior respond
to amphetamine suggesting that if we can
actually intervene early enough identify
individuals at risk based on stress
response Livity and simply treat the
stress either pharmacologically or
psycho socially as has been done by pat
mccrory in australia we might actually
certain then some of these developmental
consequences that lead to hippocampal
damage and emergence of psychosis now in
addition to mediating the attention to
salient stimuli the dopamine system is
also involved in reward related behavior
in fact all drugs of abuse work on the
dopaminergic system to some extent
multiple studies have shown that if you
attenuate the dopamine system either by
lesioning it forgiving antagonists we
can get the state of antimony and adonia
or the absence of the ability to derive
pleasure from the environment is a
primary symphony of depression where
patients don't experience pleasure for
normally rewarding events we examine the
role in dopamine system in a well-known
model of depression which is the chronic
mild stress model what we find is if we
expose rats to chronic mild stressors
and then look at classic models of
depression such as forced swim where
animals are placed in a tub of water a
shallow tub of water where they have to
try to escape what you find is that
normal rats will swim around for a
period of time find that they tend to
keep trying to escape until they find
that they can't escape and then just
become immobile and float and they do
this rather rapidly the mam treated
animals however don't show this amount
of the mobility they continue trying to
escape something we referred to as a
behavioral despair where they become the
mobile very rapidly and because they
become a mobile they basically give up
what we find is that in the animals that
have become immobile we falsifying
a change in dopaminergic neuron firing
in this case we have a tremendous
decrease by almost half in the number of
neurons firing without affecting the
other firing properties the neurons
now what pathway mediates this
attenuation of dopaminergic neuron
activity well in order to look at this
we looked at the clinical literature and
studies by Helen neighbor have
identified an area the sub general
singular for area 25 is an area
associated with depression this area is
activated by sad memories by tryptophan
depletion which is known to activate the
depressive symptoms and it's also high
in depressed patients moreover any
treatment that's effective at treating
depression giving SSRIs even placebos
when they're effective transcranial
magnetic stimulation ECT ventral nerve
stimulation all restore activity within
the sub general syndulla area 25 so
hyperactivity in this area
seems to correlate with depression if we
activate the rat equivalent of this
which is the infer limbic prefrontal
cortex what we find is the same thing we
saw in the depressed rats the decrease
by half and the number of dopaminergic
neurons firing
now this decrease a number of neurons
firing we find that we can inactivate we
can reverse and we do this by looking at
another system it's been shown to have
an involvement in depression and this is
the basal lateral amygdala in addition
to the infra limpid prefrontal cortex
being hyperactive the basal lateral
amygdala in depressed patients is hyper
responsive and in fact if we put TTX to
inactivate this this basal lateral
amygdala what we find is we prevent the
effects of NMDA and this decreases in
dopaminergic neuron firing
the depression in humans as I mentioned
has been associated with increased
amygdala activity thus the increased
amygdala activity explained the decrease
in dopaminergic neuron firing well if we
just activate the amygdala directly what
we find is the same thing is when we
activate it indirectly by activating the
infant limbic prefrontal cortex the
decrease in the number of dopaminergic
neurons firing
whereas in activating the amygdala
present reflect this suggests that the
amygdala is driving the decrease in
dopamine neuron activity furthermore if
we take our CMS induced attenuation of
dopaminergic neurons we can reverse this
depression like decrease in dopaminergic
neuron activity by either in activating
the basolateral amygdala for blocking
the reg and merging drive of the basal
lateral amygdala how does the basal
lateral amygdala attenuate dopaminergic
neuron firing the projections from the
basal lateral amygdala to the
dopaminergic neurons is not prudent but
the basal lateral amygdala has a number
of intermediate structures by which it
can affect the dopaminergic neuron
firing and one common area is the
ventral pallidum the area that we show
has an involvement with respect to the
activation in the schizophrenia model in
fact what we find is if we block the
glutamatergic projection from the
amygdala to the ventral pallidum with a
glutamate antagonists kinda reinecke
acid we can reverse the effects of
amygdala activation on dopamine neuron
firing suggesting that the activation of
the amygdala driving the attenuation of
dopaminergic neuron firing is mediated
by activation in this case the ventral
pallidum now is the infra limbic
prefrontal cortex causing this effect
well if we look at the infra limbic
prefrontal cortex and animals that
wander gone chronic mild stress what we
find is if we look at the infra limbic
prefrontal cortical inactivation we can
restore dopaminergic neuron firing in
contrast if we look at a different area
the lateral habenula an area that's also
known to decrease dopamine urging neuron
firing we don't see this kind of
attenuation suggesting that in the case
of the chronic multiple stressors
it's the infra limbic prefrontal cortex
hyperactivity the area that's also seen
to be hyperactive in depression that
activates the basolateral amygdala and
area hyper responsive and depression
over drives the ventral pallidum and
inhibits dopaminergic neuron fire so in
depression what we have is an amygdala
down regulation of the dopaminergic
system a big decrease in the number of
neurons firing so that the stimulus
that's normally associated with reward
will cause a much smaller dopamine
activation now the consequence is that
we're going to have a failure to
activate the dopamine system to normally
rewarding stimuli so we have our two
circuits the dopamine activating circuit
working through the ventral Civic ulam
inhibits the pallidum and a dopamine
inhibiting circuit that works through
the amygdala to activate the palatal
therefore we have independent systems
that can either activate or attenuate
dopaminergic neuron responsibly given
that the ventral hippocampus provides an
excitatory Drive in the dopaminergic
neurons but the amygdala provides an
inhibitory Drive what controls the
balance between this excitation and
ambition in order to do this we used a
much more rapid way of inducing the
depress state in animal models and this
is the learned helplessness model this
is something that was actually developed
by Seligmann a large number of more than
50 years ago
what we do is we expose animals to an
environment where they have an
inescapable mild shock not a painful
shock but just enough that it's
disturbing to them in this case there's
a barrier and they can't really escape
the shot after one day of this what we
do is we give them an escape route and
what we find under these conditions is
half the animals escape they showed
normal escape responses but half the
animals are helpless they don't escape
because they've learned that they aren't
able to control their environment
something that we think happens with
respect to depressed patients as well so
in non helpless animals they don't fail
to escape the helpless animals they do
fail to escape now interestingly there's
a technique that's been shown that's
been fun to be quite effective and
rapidly treating depression
whereas antidepressant drugs take weeks
to months in order to have efficacy and
even then don't have high efficacy
across a large number of patients recent
studies have shown that enemy will
actually have a rapid antidepressant
effect and in fact if we give tending to
these animals we make the helpless
animals look like they're not helpless
animals they now start to escape now
what about when we look at dopaminergic
neuron firing well interestingly even
though these animals received identical
food shock treatment the animals that
escaped the non helpless animals showed
no change in the dopamine system but the
helpless animals show a significant
attenuation of dopaminergic neuron fired
whenever we give the animals kidney what
we find is that in addition to restoring
escape behavior we also restored
dopaminergic neuron fire how does this
occur well in order to do this we looked
at the other pathway the activating
pathway
in other words we've stimulated the
hippocampus and recorded of oaked
activity in the amygdala and what we
find whenever we activate this
glutamatergic pathway is just what you
would expect by activating and
glutamatergic pathway LTP but in
helpless animals instead of getting a
long-term potentiation what we get is
just the opposite a long-term depression
in other words in the helpless animals
this essential excitatory pathway is
shut off giving ketamine will reverse
this inhibition into an excitation so it
actually reverses the stimulation
induced depression to a normal
stimulation induced potentiation so what
we have is a case where we have the
dopamine activating circuit imbalance
with the dopamine inhibiting circuit but
in learned helplessness model and
presumably other models the excitatory
pathway is an activator which means only
the inhibitory pathway predominates now
what we've been talking about are things
related to activation and schizophrenia
and in addition to depression but these
aren't opposite disorders how can we
come to grips with the fact that these
are having different types of behavioral
and clinical effects well it seems to
have to do with the dopamine systems
involved because the dopamine system is
really a multi-faceted area we have the
amygdala circuit but it projects to the
ventromedial stratum that's involved in
reward this is the area and we think is
involved in depression on the other hand
the area that seems to be activated the
dopaminergic system that's activated in
schizophrenia as shown by mark Norell
and Anissa abby garden is the associated
stratum that interconnects with dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex so what we
have is a limbic circuit that's involved
in the inhibition and
an associative circuit that's involving
the excitation so by decreasing
dopaminergic neuron population activity
in the reward related area we get a
decrease in dopaminergic responsiveness
this would contrast the activation of
the dopamine system in schizophrenia
which would lead to disruptions and
higher cortical functions in stimulus
interpretation so these studies suggest
that the dopamine system can play
distinct roles in both schizophrenia and
depression hyperactivity in the ventral
hippocampus can activate ventral
tegmental area from an urgent neuron
activity via this ventral hippocampus
the company's inhibition of the ventral
pallidum leading the disinhibition and
excitation of dopamine neurons in
contrast inescapable stressors are going
to decrease dopamine neuron activity via
this inframan ik cortex amygdala
excitation of the bencher colony
inhibiting dopaminergic neuron activity
so although the dopamine system may form
the basis of a number of psychiatric
disorders the pathology is likely not to
originate in the dopaminergic system
itself but in areas that control their
activity as a consequence that therapy
based on restoring normal function in
these regions is likely to be more
effective than directly manipulating
dopamine receptor stimulation of course
I would like to thank that large number
of people who were involved in this work
the people on the left are the people
that have worked in my lab currently in
over the years that have done work on
these systems and are really responsible
for all of the different work that I've
done there that I presented to you as
well as our collaborators in Pittsburgh
as well as in other areas that have
contributed substantially to this work
and I'd like to thank you and I'm glad
to answer any questions that you may
have right now
question that I've received is does this
area involve the HPA axis it says it
seems that schizophrenia patients have a
lot of behaviors and thoughts about
paranoia and as I mentioned it does seem
to involve the HPA axis the HPA axis we
think is actually part of the area that
we think is involved in this hyper
responsibility of stress and in fact pat
mccrory in australia have shown that in
early onset schizophrenia patients
there's an activation and an increased
size of the hippocampus lamech area
involved in the HPA axis again another
thing that we think is involved in the
transition of increased response to
stress that eventually leads to these
deficit states another question what
happens neurobiologically during the
catatonic phase of schizophrenia this is
really a good question
and it's something that hasn't been
studied there's certainly a number of
ways that you could speculate about this
it could be possible that it may be that
there is a overdrive of the dopamine
system to the point where the dopamine
system is not responsive at all
something that may be depolarization
block something you've seen can occur it
would basically shut down the system or
it could be something that's actually
translating from the limbic system to
the motor system studies by Suzanne
Hebert showed that activation of the
limbic system can lead to changes in the
motor system and it may be that if the
limbic system is overacting the motor
system is going to be the one that's
going to be over driven that's going to
suffer as well and possibly lead to
catatonia another question saying it's
pure speculation but though I think that
there's an evolutionary reason to have
latent predisposition of a number of
subjects do a depressive phenotype
that's a good question it's always a
question about what happens are these
pure disorders or earning they have some
functional effect well a speculation it
could be that depression actually does
have a evolutionary
effect depending on the amount of
depression and its consequence for so
for example in the case of chronic
multiple stressors if an animal
venturing from its burrow is constantly
exposed de-stresses it may be
evolutionarily advantageous to not leave
their burrow and to hide from these
stressors until the threat passes so in
this case depression may actually be
somewhat adapted to a very dangerous
environment on the other hand what the
case were we're talking about here it's
not adaptive intends to be extensive
now the helpless animals tend to have
helpless littermates this is really an
interesting question we we haven't
really looked at how this changes
whenever we look at how it translates
across parents to offspring there are a
lot of epigenetic factors things that
have done been done a lot by a number of
investigators such as Tracy bales among
others showing the changes that you make
to the adult can actually translate the
changes that occur in the offspring so
there is a possibility that the effects
that we produce in the adult animal in
the animal at gestation are going to
translate to its offspring now whether
this translates the litter mates is
really an interesting thing in other
words when you look at litter mates do
we have an entire cohort of helpless
versus a cohort of non helpless we
haven't seen evidence for this we
haven't looked closely enough and it's
something that's really an excellent
idea a question how can I measure
anhedonia and rats Antonia is
challenging because it's the perception
of the ward now anhedonia has typically
been measured using a sucrose preference
test where you give rats a choice
between drinking sucrose or drinking
water
even studies that have shown positive
effects in this have shown rather mild
effects only a change of between 80 to
90 percent 80% to 90% preference or I
should say 90 to 80% preference on the
other hand an approach that John Solomon
uses might be something that more
recapitulates what we see in the
depressed patient depressed patients are
happy to have the ward
the thing is is the pressed patients
aren't willing to go out and obtain the
reward they aren't willing to expend
effort so better measure from John
Solomon's data would be whether the rats
are actually willing to expend effort in
order to get reward rather than choose
to get reward or not and this is
something we're currently looking into
in collaboration with John Selmer
another question have we looked at the
central amygdala nucleus and mam treated
on this face rats
we really haven't this is really a
recent area of investigation for us and
we're basically just how the resources
to finish looking at the amygdala right
now but it's certainly something you
would like to look at in the future
another question how do I correlate the
lack of response to pre pulse inhibition
in animal models in schizophrenia with a
massive firing of the urgent neurons
causing increased anxiety well the thing
about increased anxiety this increased
anxiety may change the initial response
to the stimulus but what we're looking
at here is Jayden so whenever we adjust
the response to the same proportional
response to a given stimulus but we look
as as to the response to the testicles
and it's the response to this test
stimulus that doesn't occur whether
anxiety plays a role in that isn't clear
it probably doesn't play a big role
because just anxiety alone doesn't lead
to changes in creep on submission but it
also must be understood the pre pulse in
addition itself although it's a
necessary requisite isn't really
selected for schizophrenia as it seemed
in a number of other types disorders
that
all these dopaminergic hippocampal
circuits do I have any collaboration
with Africans I don't but I would really
like to extend a collaboration to
Africans that are interested in
especially in following up in these
types of models I think through things
like the CI NP the International
Congress of neuropsychopharmacology as
well as CERN's the schizophrenia
international research society are
mechanisms that we can actually extend
these types of collaborations through
the CI NP within the the schizophrenia
Society we've extended collaborations to
India and extending them to Africa I
think can only benefit everyone another
question can I comment on the
observation that schizophrenia often
appears around or following puberty when
neurobiological changes occur around
that time that might affect this well
there are a number of changes that occur
around puberty interestingly it's not
puberty itself but the laid out a lesson
period or schizophrenia occurs generally
in the late teens or early 20s which is
well past puberty now this is a time
when the prefrontal cortex is undergoing
further development and it's also a time
whenever functions that are mediated
exclusively by the hippocampus are
handed off if you will to the prefrontal
cortex so if the prefrontal cortex isn't
functioning it's not going to have the
ability to regulate the types of stress
related symptoms that are going to be
more and more prevalent as someone
reaches young adults with when people
become independent of the parents when
they're forced to fend for themselves
general life stresses as well as the
changes in the brain that may
necessitate these kinds of alterations
the question what I care to comment on
how talk therapies have the ability to
change physical morphology of the brain
and what therapy would synergize best
with acute drug therapy well in this
case it's going to depend on which
disease in which stage of the disease I
think when you're talking about the
premorbid state when you're looking at
people that are at risk for
schizophrenia and that risk for
depression
things that can mitigate the effects of
stress things like the pat mccrory has
been doing in australia with respect to
psychosocial intervention can have a
very positive effect so you don't really
need to treat stress people with IPAM
you could actually get better
psychosocial intervention in order to
try to mitigate these effects this is
something that's been classically
classically observed in Sao Paulo Brazil
Sao Paulo Brazil in the barrios
surrounding this area is known to have a
much lower incidence of major
psychiatric disorders but also tends to
have a very high level of family support
groups and it's thought to be that these
family support groups may be mitigating
the effects of stress that without these
interventions could lead the pathologies
when you get through the adult the thing
that you need to do is restore the
neurochemical balance there have been a
number of studies that have shown that
top therapies themselves don't have high
impact when it comes to hospitalization
recovery unless the patients have their
systems restored once you treat the
neurochemical balance then allowing the
people to reintegrate with talk therapy
is essential question how do we
disengage the HPA axis on a patient that
has been diagnosed with a deadly cancer
issue it is the HPA axis shut down the
immune system that's a good question
the HPA axis can be shut down in number
of ways it can certainly be done
chemically by blocking some of these
stress hormones but I think as it's been
shown in these studies and also studies
that have been done looking at people
with PTSD you need to be able to mount
the stress response in order to have a
homeostatic response to the stress on
the other hand controlling the stress
itself might actually be a better way to
get around these types of missions
another question is there anything known
about the biological basis of lack of
insight seen in half of the
schizophrenia patients that's
interesting the lack of insight could
have to do with the cognitive decline
because you generally have insight
whenever you have the cognitive ability
to interpret what's happening to you and
the cognitive decline can happen from a
number of ways we know that the ventral
hippocampus has projections to the
prefrontal cortical areas that are
involved in cognition the cingulate
areas to areas that are involved in
stimulus interpretation so when the
hippocampus is hyperactive it can drag
down a number of braids brain areas that
are involved in stimulus interpretation
and stimulus salience it also might be
the case that whenever people have an
activated dopamine system they tend to
be in a more delusional state because
the dopamine system is going to be
hyperactive whenever you're presented
with the stimulus when somebody tells
them that something is wrong they're
more likely that they'll interpret this
as an attack on them rather than helpful
selection and under such types of
conditions the inability to interpret
things in a more benign way may actually
exacerbate the lack of insight the lack
of ability to really understand what's
happening to the patient that's the last
of the questions that I've had I would
like now to go to the CME areas to
obtain continuing education credits
please go to this website this website
will give you information as far as the
CME the types of questions you need to
answer and how to obtain credit thank
you very much for your attention
and I'm happy to be able to participate
and thank you for your attention during
this process